what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and mcu
and i think pretty much everybody really
really loved if not heavily enjoyed
spider-man no way home in fact i watched
it again a couple of days ago and one of
my all-time favorite movies just in
general not even just with marvel but in
general and of course a lot of that has
to do with the movie simply being
amazing but everything that led up to
spider-man no way home was also a pretty
big part of the whole journey because we
had been talking about toby maguire
spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man showing up in no way home a
year before it came out probably a
little bit more than a year before it
came out and this was all pretty
exciting to us but as you can imagine
this was a huge secret that was not
supposed to get out and apparently it
had some of the people worried and
andrew garfield was one of those people
because they took a lot of precautions
to make sure that there were really no
leaked photos and then all of a sudden
there were and recently andrew garfield
has commented on how him and sony kind
of reacted to some of these leaks
getting out so let's go over what andrew
garfield recently said about when a
leaked photo of him got out and of
course if you love marvel and want to
stay up to date on everything be sure to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so i'm not exactly sure what the first
leaked photo was i think it was of
andrew garfield the one where his arm is
on the pull the leaked video also came
with that where it looked like he was
saying webb blood which we now know
thanks to the movie it was web block but
i think this was the first if not one of
the first photos that came out it was
definitely the first photo of andrew
garfield the first leak of him and of
course andrew garfield saw these photos
and this was his reaction to the photos
and with the studio in an interview he
told cinema blend this is what he said i
worked so hard to keep it secret that i
was in atlanta shooting all these leaks
were happening and i was like oh my gosh
guys what the hell is going on i'm
working so hard here to stay secret and
then here's an image of me with toby and
they're like no no we're gonna keep it
quiet okay i'll keep denying it now
there are a few photos that are kind of
all the same they're all from the same
scene and to the best of my knowledge
those were really the only photos leaked
that and the one of matt murdock but
there were two photos specifically
leaked of andrew garfield and toby
maguire one was the john campbell photo
that showed the three spider-men and
then there was another one that showed
toby and andrew sitting right next to
each other this was on the statue of
liberty of course and they had the
scaffolding behind them this we now know
because of the statue of liberty being
remodeled to include the captain america
shield which i don't think is going to
happen anymore since it you know kind of
fell but as you can see here these
photos getting out kind of made andrew
garfield mad he did a lot to stay secret
and as we know a ton of people were
asking him about spider-man no way home
there are countless videos out there of
simply fans meeting him at the premieres
of other movies asking him about no way
home he goes on talk shows and jimmy
fallon is sitting there saying we saw a
leaked photo we know you're in the movie
and andrew garfield's saying no i'm not
next thing you know he is on another
talk show saying no i'm not in the film
i'm not the werewolf and get this he
went to such extents to keep this a
secret to keep his cameo and knowing
home a secret that he didn't even tell
emma stone gwen stacy from the amazing
spider-man franchise that he was in the
movie he recently opened up and he said
that emma stone would text him asking if
he was going to be in spiderman no way
home because she heard all of the rumors
and he would reply to her i don't know
what you're talking about i'm not in the
movie so as you can tell andrew garfield
was pretty upset that leaked photos of
him were getting out but what's even
more interesting is sony's response they
said no no we're going to keep quiet
even though there are these leaked
photos out there of you of toby of tom
all together we're going to keep quiet
about it we're not going to confirm
you're in the movie and that was their
marketing strategy moving forward with
spider-man no way home even though all
of these leaks were happening even
though a year before the film came out
people were saying toby maguire and
andrew garfield are returning and
they're going to be in the movie sony
decided and this was their reaction to
it we're not going to say anything ever
we're never going to confirm this we're
not going to show them the trailers
we'll hint at it a little bit just to
get people excited but we're never going
to confirm it and you know what it
worked it created a ton of hype and
excitement and it still made you
question whether or not they were going
to be in the movie even for people like
me who were 99 sure they were going to
be in the film i still had one percent
of doubt because sony never confirmed it
and i went in super excited just not
knowing and it made for a much better
experience now it is unfortunate that
these photos got out and that andrew
garfield did try so hard to remain
secretive but i also think that he did a
pretty good job kind of trying to
convince people that hey this photo's
fake it's photoshopped because let's be
honest there are some really really good
photoshops out there and when he said
it's fake and it's photoshopped a lot of
us thought yeah
maybe it actually could be because
people are really good at photoshops
nowadays but it was real and andrew was
in the film along with toby maguire and
i'm actually surprised only a few photos
were leaked so that's andrew reacting
and sony reacting to the leaks how they
all handled it and i think it was
handled in a pretty decent way but let
me know what you think about it leave
your thoughts down below in the comments
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things happening in the marvel universe
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof